Buonasera salve
ormai sono di casa vi ricordate marina e
tu sei preparata? si
allora i cugini di caltanissetta i cugini calabresi la
famiglia di trieste di tuo fratello
nonna luisa e poi le cuginette alice clotilde eli si ce l'ho fatta
mi sono permessa di nuovo visto che edoardo mi ha detto che vi è piaciuto molto il vino
che vi ho portato a natale ne ho presi
due così avete la scorta senti tu però
a natale non c'era la famiglia di nizza
presentale anche tutti i cugini
francesi allora cominciamo da lì alain
alon vincent e poi i cuginettini
piccolini che sono calí crignot e benjamin
è facile da ricordare poi l'altro
zio invece ha sposato una ragazza
algerina che ha tre figliolini che sono
malika said ahmed ok li studio per la
prossima volta
bella raga finalmente vi presento Edo ve ne ho parlato tanto oh bella ma come fai a sopportarla?
lui é un pó precisino ma poi si scioglie la
camicia un pó cosí ma ci piace lo stesso
lo facciamo integrare nel nostro gruppo eh? amore bello
senti marina cosa ti faccio da bere vuoi bere qualcosa?
guardi visto che é capodanno mi
andrebbe tantissimo un vodka lemon
una limonata limonata il 31 dicembre non ce l'ho ma dove l'hai recuperata questa?
ti posso fare un caffè un decaffeinato no guardi il caffè é intollerante al caffè
neanche il caffè bevi ma eh allora un tè
una tisana ti faccio guarda una tisana con
la passiflora che ho raccolto io questa
primavera va bene? va bene buona
amore mettiti questa cosí sei un pó più Capodanno
comunque ho portato del vino un roero arnais asciutto color paglierino amore noi
siamo abituati a cose un po più strong
anche lui lui praticamente beve solo
rum quindi facciamo così scendiamo al volo é ancora aperto 3 bottiglie di vodka
tre di tequila due minimo di rum andiamo tu tieni compagnia a Edo eh tranquilla ciao a dopo
si abbina bene con formaggi e antipasti
giulia ma allora la scuola come va eh
va bene nonna ma l'ho finita da un pó la
scuola non ho capito
l'ho finita da un pó la scuola nonna
cosa fai adesso lavori? e si sto cercando
di fare qualche stage cerco un pó  brava
mi raccomando che è importante eh questo guadagnare lavorando tu invece quali
sono i tuoi propositi per l'anno nuovo
dimmi un pó eh io voglio andare a
ballare uscire fare le cose divertirmi
nonna bisogna divertirsi qui
hai voglia tempo di divertirsi adesso devi
lavorare studiare e mettere la testa a
posto che ballare non va bene ma portala in giro con te portala a messa
ogni tanto che questa qui la vedo
un pó che se ne sta andando per la
strada sbagliata
allora propositi per l'anno nuovo?
io vorrei disinvestire - non dire matrimonio- disinvestire un paio di - non dire un bambino - vorrei disinvestire
un paio di obbligazioni per comprare casa e sfruttare il boom edilizio ma cosa gli avete messo acqua?
ma bevi bevi bevi bevi
10 - 9 - 8 - 7 - 6 - 5 - 4 - 3 - 2 - 1
auguri amore auguri ormai siamo cugine no? auguri ciao cara auguri buon anno
auguri auguri buon anno
12 - 10 - 6 - 9 - 8 - 5-  6 - 4 - 3 no 2 - no 1
AUGURI EEEEEEEEE cin buon anno amore
bevi tutto a goccia bravo amore e allora anche questo 2019 ce lo siamo levati dalle palle
e adesso cosa facciamo beviamo ancora o ma alziamo sta musica ma mettimi sfera e basta
puzzle l'abbiamo fatto scala quaranta
l'abbiamo fatta possiamo andare anche a letto no?
volentieri si dai che la tisanina della
nonna mi ha messo un sonno é fortissima quella tisana si andiamo
buonanotte a domani notte ci vediamo
domani mattina ciao
allora ti sei divertita? da morire
amore vero bellissimo sono proprio dei matti
amore gira balla come una trottola il flamenco lo ballo anche io ragazzi noi dobbiamo andare peró
grazie la serata é stata bellissima siete dei grandi davvero
però adesso... senti un pó ma forse non ti sei accorto che qua noi
ti abbiamo accolto nel nostro gruppo
ora tu non te ne vai da nessuna parte
anzi questo lo bevi tutto fino
all'ultima goccia bitch forza tutto giú giú giú giú
tutta salute amore ma é uno scherzo te ne puoi andare quando vuoi none none
buongiorno ciao ma ti sei già cambiata?  no ho dormito così non potevi chiedere un
pigiama a loro veramente ne avevamo solo due si vuoi un pezzetto di merendina? no grazie
amore preferisco mangiare fuori
beh comunque che serata ieri eh ci siamo divertiti un botto anche se non come quella volta in cui il
nonno aveva buttato l' apparecchio di sara nell'immondizia e abbiamo cercato per tutta la città
ma chi é che l'aveva trovato? io l'avevo trovato no l'aveva trovato la zia io l'avevo
trovato che storia divertente
oh ma dove siamo? le luci i sassi e le palline ma é ancora natale?
ma c'é un regalo di natale apriamolo ma chi é? é il tuo fidanzato
ma ci assomiglia ma non mi ricordo che ci fosse anche lui
ma amore dai svegliati guarda come ti sei ridotto! facciamo la guerra dei cuscini? siii tutti su edoardo
con le altre fatto faccio lo stupido ho bevuto troppo meglio se ti riportano da te
gli sto insegnando tutte le canzoni di sfera e basta perché il prossimo capodanno mettiamo
sfera e basta va bene? basta si ci dobbiamo rinnovare e mi raccomando ragazzi iscrivetevi al
canale e mettete i mi piace e commentate
facendoci sapere se passerete il
capodanno con la famiglia con la nonna
oppure con gli amici
meglio la famiglia ciao ragazzi buon anno un bacione e fate i bravi eh i bravi